if you yesterday that for a year and you
haven't said it breakup you're right
like breakup that's yeah I was telling a
story like I was with a guy for a year
and I was just waiting for him to say I
love you I knew he did by his actions
like the way he high-fived me after sex
[Music]
fred is here everyone from SNL and the
movie pop star which is my favorite
comedy movie in the past decade I would
say yeah it's such a funny
standard well Chris read you're killing
it on SNL doesn't mean you're gonna kill
it we've seen so many times people come
and go and I remember when you got it I
was just like I hope he makes a splash
and you certainly have I mean you are
going to have such longevity on that
show if you want it and and in your
career you've just you've always been
talented but it's just so nice to see
you just really people acknowledging it
and and you what is it like being over
there are you still frightened every
time you walk in the building I mean it
had to have started that way were you
like so intimidated I wasn't I wasn't
really intimidated by Lauren or or like
the show it is just really the I learned
how much anxiety actually have which is
crazy because it's such there's so much
pressure to it then there's like the
people that you get they get to have
opinions about your work all the time
yeah and I wasn't really used to that
and but I'm very curious to knows Witter
or produce every internet every I know
it's not so much I'm surprised you have
time to even see Brad first of all if
you're on the show a lot people you're
selling three sketches so the rest of
the time I'm sitting there watching the
show at everybody else and I'm just on
Twitter saying what's Hayden see it's
kind of like on stage like you know you
hear those laughs like oh I know this
jokes working like that's how it feels
thank you every Saturday you're trending
unless like there's somebody on there
that no one knows right right then you
like it transacted effect right weird
but you can see exactly how things are
hitting like
like immediately so I'm I'm like all
interested in that do you like that or
you like this yeah you know but uh but I
kind of like it when it's going well
it's like overwhelmingly positive focus
on the one chord 72 I let it go I was in
a bad place when I made that account
your Kanye was fantastic and that is not
that was an easy role to do how did you
prepare for that well they told me I was
gonna do it on Friday
that's great cuz it's like I only have
this amount of time I can't overthink it
you just do like that you just
start watching videos I'm like a huge
huge fan and so I've already I have this
very complicated like feeling about
Kanye now I have for a very long time
and so I was just like listening to the
music and then and it was I was already
doing and then just watching his
watching that meeting a bunch like and
kind of seeing where his points were and
like how he felt his intensity and just
trying to match the things that was fun
for me to do and and I just had to watch
it over and over again to the point
where I was like you know he's not wrong
oh so you were able to become him when
you were able to empathize with him a
little bit and see his perspective so it
wasn't like let me just find a way to
ridicule this person with my impression
but let me try to be him and see where
he's coming from and attack that
impression from that 100% I just thought
I said I've too much empathy for
everything so that's just kind of like a
thing I get from my grandma Hey and my
mom's you know did they pass that
down so I care about things that are
really weird but but yeah for me he's oh
he's a rich guy that became like this
headline guy he's like a kind of a Chuck
yeah he wants to bring the world
together he's doing it wrong
and doing it the way but a lot of us
don't agree with but everything he's
saying wasn't crazy like stop stop and
frisk is like a thing we need you don't
mean he's always been that way
he's just been more informed in how to
do it and now he's just you know he's
just yeah he's like you can't you can't
say oh I'm on the side of the guy who
has kids in cages and like just but this
is fun and we should do this you gotta
read just feels like he wants to be
subversive to I don't know like he wants
to make headlines yeah he wants to be
that it's like it's like ego with like
the ego with good ideas and then like no
no reading yeah not being medically
treated at the time he's not taking his
meds yeah he's not he's not on his meds
now he's down his medication but he also
relies a little bit so you don't know
what exactly what an athlete doesn't let
me ask you about when you're actually
working on an impression was there a
nuance and his voice or a way he said a
certain word where you're like I'm
definitely gonna say that word because I
can really nail that like what yeah he
has this thing where he tries to hide
his Chicago and and but but then it
comes out when he gets excited so that
that growl like you know you know that
very thing he tries to hide it cuz he's
talking to white people so he's like so
he's trying to like not hide it but then
it comes out anyway it was like watching
two people fight in the same throat was
there a line you especially loved saying
because you were like oh do you slip
when you're because sometimes when I'm
doing an impression there's a moment
where I'm like I really feel like I'm
them and I can only hold on to it for
like a second sometimes frustrates me
and it's hard to maintain it how did you
maintain it yeah I mean IIIi mean it I'm
still working on I've done the the
impressions maybe two days old yeah but
it's it's it's when like when he says
stuff like time those things I can dive
into I like the I like playing with that
and just like anytime he just gets to
height it's like that's because that's
the energy that he puts on to the all of
his albums and that's a song Kanye I can
do even better than hurry up with my
damn Chris all on her yet with my damn
consign
I love that I want to make I got so I'm
gonna make a song as him next to help me
like what happen were you listening to
do to get oh man I was oh yeah which I
listen to most the time yeah Dark
Twisted Fantasy is just so perfect
oh it's it's the perfect album that
amazing Friday I think it's I think it
started the Kanye that we see though
because he put all of his issues on that
record appraised it so so then he's like
no people praise my crazy and then
that's just like the Anunnaki way we
could talk about yeah yeah honestly but
uh I do I do think like he's once he
started putting his weird thoughts on
record you know I mean new slaves all
that all that like Jesus we started
just like yeah we like you and you're
crazy it's like oh I'm just gonna be
crazy with something else that she'll
agree with over beats but also thought
it was a genius I love you know I came
up and shuffle for me yesterday at the
best time I was working out and it was
Kanye's workout so - walks is one of my
favorites oh my god it just makes you
here it was like right around the time
where hip-hop was like don't talk about
Jesus it was like I'm gonna do it but
he's been the same guy the whole time
like don't press the red button he
presses now choosing the one side of
things that's like pissing people off
mm-hmm but that's always been him yeah
yeah you just wish he just you know read
a book of what book would you reckon you
could
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
any book by any author so is it what has
been the the most unexpected part of
working at SNL for you you walk in we
all walk in we would all walk into SNL
with like I think I know what this is
gonna be I've read the books I've heard
the interviews what was the most
unexpected thing for you the most
unexpected was how cool how cool Lauren
is like it's like oh he's like an OG and
I'm I'm used to like old-school like
gangster types and he's very much that
he's very nice dude and there's like a
lot of other things that like he just
knows there's so many stories about him
that that he's like you can't stop them
all everybody everybody like good
version of Lauren that I thought I was
gonna get fired so much for like and I
realized that wasn't like you know
you're not gonna get as far as much as
you think you are but also you could and
then I you know what I saw did you see
Lauren on Norma Donald show oh I really
recommend watching it because I've
always thought of him as someone to fear
and I'm just like this guy just seems
mean for no reason and just like stuck
up and I just there's never been a part
of me that's like I can't wait to meet
Lauren Michaels someday he just seems
like frightening but he is so sweet and
funny and soft
[Music]
yeah he's a dope dude it he runs like a
super crazy powerful business with
you're like dope just to watch and be a
part of I guess but in the crowd the
crowd of stage I thought it was gonna be
a lot like bigger and I got a lot more
intimidating and it's not when I've been
to SNL the one time I went when amy
hosted it it felt like going to see my
friend in a play in high school that's
what it felt like again it gave me that
same like oh my god I can't believe my
friend is it but it's like watching a
play it
it's so fast it's so crazy now the code
open wasn't nerve-racking like crazy cuz
I knew how we knew what it meant to the
show and I'm playing on lost Alec who
knows I'm gonna kill it and right in
front of me I'm like oh man and so I'm
just hoping it was and nothing felt good
in to live like live just rehearsal felt
alright because I was new were the
laughs were but like live was when it
was like okay okay yeah I feel like you
have reached this point now where mamede
Ian's and as artists we always just
think we're tricking everyone to
thinking we're talented and they're like
we've tricked the system I shouldn't be
doing this right now
but when you get on SNL they make so
many good decisions and they have a
track record of making great decisions
do you at that point go okay I am good
yeah this is validating enough to be
like I should be here right now I'm
gonna come out and nail this does it
give you that yeah I started to slip
away because at first it was it was very
much like I'm a student of the game and
I'm just learning how to move in this is
like okay and I'm just gonna try to
figure out where I want my legacy to be
just I just try to up myself every time
and come in here just try to kill it and
bring what I bring to the show and yeah
I feel way more comfortable that's the
second year is like breeze anybody
coming into the show man just just get
through the first year yeah I mean I'm
not gonna say you straight there
shouldn't be hard years I've seen people
have hard years you know yeah and they
tell me all the time you know you're
here for some good times right now I
wasn't there when Trump was there so
there's a lot of things that happen you
could go anyway which is something I
like about it oh yeah
well then posture syndrome thing that I
always go back to a therapist once said
to me she was like who do you think you
are that you're tricking everyone do you
think that these people are stupid and
you when you're on SNL you're dealing
with Lorne Michaels is this he's made
the smartest comedy decisions and so
it's like you haven't if you were able
to trick him and weasel your way on this
you know like right if Lorne Michaels
picks you it's validating of like okay I
am talented yeah and I'm glad you got
that because you are and yeah it's just
it's so exciting to see you become
famous and like dress better
my god walk into a club and I'm like
Chris Reds rich just wearing the same
clothes for so long my friend gave me a
shirt one thing about the show well we
got this like a fashion show for some of
us what it chase always fly this exam
Jake he's always flag a rich dude one of
the writers always fly so we're just
kind of like we're always coming in with
new new shoes and she's like yeah
yeah look what I got it was one thing
you know like people I just assumed
you're a Democrat because you're on the
show which is a very weird thing I'm
like I'm not any of them like political
games I don't really care that much my
vote for who makes sense to me like but
people just put you in like oh you're
there so you're that and like everybody
on the show is not one of the other but
but like a lot of the right makes it
seem like I'm like a lot of things I
write aren't even political in the show
film like I'm just lying social socially
political stuff it has nothing to do
with the you guys talk about but
they put you in that box which is very
weird
cuz they're they feel like they're in a
box so everybody's in the box putting
those boxes just a bunch of boxes
running around I'm like wow so everybody
gets so seriously intense about SNL and
they criticize it like I give a
like last year the worst that's you want
people talking about the show in any way
I mean that's what keeps it alive gotta
go to break but I can't wait to spend
another will you stick around I'm
chilling I'm chilling man okay I can't
wait thank you Chris rad is here
everyone we are back in studio right now
with us Tom to car Ian finance and crisp
red from SNL whoo Chris so excited to
have you in
so sad to be here I love me some neat
ways oh my god
I love some crisp red we've just become
friends and I would say right before you
got SNL I kind of like became buds with
you yeah yeah it was crazy and I cuz we
had planned to go to lunch and then I I
had to move quick and couldn't say why
so I just had to dip asshole
cuz I had so many different plans that
week too I had finally started like in
LA I finally started like finding like a
friend group friend groups I really
liked to with and then I had to
just leave and then I couldn't save
nothing for a week and then would you
tell people duh some people I just
didn't well I'm not a great text backer
anyway several people will say that yeah
I mean no I answer you all the time but
yeah but like I am I'm genuinely like
not great at it
so for some people I could just not say
anything and then once the news came out
oh I get it
but it was like some people like I mean
I comics get I get in with me because I
because it's a usually like something
I'm dealing with right away or I mean
like a week I'm gonna see you out so hit
you bet because you're a comic but if
you take a regular person ain't got time
thought to work right talking about
dating and stuff it's it's so difficult
I've seen you on the celebrity dating
app rheya oh yeah I was oh yes I think
you're still active on there even if you
don't want to be yeah I mean it's like
off my phone oh no it might be it might
be still on my phone honestly but
something with these dating apps you
like take them off your phone but you're
still on there I have to like go disable
your account the way I jumped on those
on those apps is knock'em is not
believable it's very true I did this
social experiment with the Moses storm
like four years ago and my character
it's like it was like a half prank show
half-written scripted and so what we
were trying to do is have people come to
this red light that it was a text
friendly light we would have it so it
lasted a lot longer so people can get
their get their texts out so the whole
thing was was like my character was like
the serial dater so I jumped on all the
apps to like
people to come to the street so they can
so we can like with them at this
text friendly light and so and then
after that I just stayed on all the apps
guys just didn't really give a and
then and then I've got addicted to just
swiping so anytime I'd be on tour I
would like see who and I would play that
game for a while and then I just have
the app so numbs on these apps and so
people tell me all the time I don't
really like use them that much and you
can't you can't talk to I mean you're
not like gonna meet up with me any
quicker I'm just still an image on your
phone that is not you maybe but you know
now though with Instagram that's how I
think people can get in touch with
celebrities if they want slide into
their nothing on Instagram is preventing
you from sending me a message and B
maybe seeing it I've met more people off
of Instagram just like yo I'm doing
shows kind of show whatever it does it's
the same thing it's the same exact thing
is like OkCupid over because you don't
have to match with them like right you
just met you can just reach out and
message people yeah I like the other day
Padma Lakshmi slid into my dny and asked
me to do a show that she's putting on in
Brooklyn and I was like I can't believe
Padma I would have like missed her
message had knocked onto that weird
folder there's someone that's like
important just like you do or you look
for someone to say something in those
first couple lines cuz all you can see
are the first line you try to look at
the tiny
yes yes but it's I mean that's the new
way everyone is meeting each other
including like celebrities whoever I
think that though Instagram is the new
dating app but I don't mind did you go
on any dates from dating apps have you
ever been on yo so I went on I went oh
my god
I went on one from bumble you know and
it was this girl who was like I met but
it took us about a year to actually go
out because I was on tour right yeah and
I was and every time I was back in New
York I only had like an like a day you
know like yeah I'm not gonna like with
us around right yeah that'd be crazy so
there so like at the end of this summer
actually is like when we went out on a
date and I took it as solo house right
and and remember yeah you had I don't be
so how exclusive it's just a cool place
to go hang out have meetings get work
done there's a gym there's just a place
you can go when you go there you pay
full price for everything but to be a
member of it to even be able to dine
there or get a drink there have a
meeting there you have to pay I would I
would go to the one in Chicago and do
shows and and the one in LA and and then
they were like yeah if you do one more
show for us we'll make you a member and
so I was like kind of like that started
I kept card in a coffee Shack
and then when I got to Ludlow
okay Yasmine was one of the directors
over there still is and and I did I did
her show and she was like you know we
gotta make you a member I was like yeah
one of those shows in here because it's
not no black one here so I need any I'm
gonna throw more shows and so that was
kind of like the goal it still is
so now I but I just I take advantage
like I love I love that spot this is
like very low-key what a great date
place too so I brought this girl to Soho
yeah we had we had these drinks you know
the drinks are amazing there and we're
sitting there and I'm like just getting
to know her and I'm realizing she
doesn't ask in any questions and she's
like I don't really talk I just I'm just
but she wasn't really she wasn't that
she wasn't dad banging where it was like
she was acting like she belonged it so
house but she's only living at equinox
she's she's not like a prototype of a
person she sound like she sounded like
she plugged herself up before you go to
bed it's like a robot right I was like
so what do you do I'm like just man just
talk and you just listen the whole time
she's like yeah pretty much like that's
that's like that's a technique that I've
read about in books where it's like how
to get a guy it's just listen don't talk
shut up yeah she was trying to can shut
up once you're in a relationship or you
can start talking about you're in
relationship but shut up before that
because I just want to talk about
Cosmopolitan article me lady I want to
talk to a person I already have 10 ways
to get sexy abs
[Laughter]
[Music]
did she know who you were beforehand oh
I think she knew me from disjointed and
that's what took me a long time to even
go out with her in the first place
because it was like I write what's what
what are you and disjointed Oh
I not play this we did okay but people
just I don't know that assume you're
like your character yeah and so or I
want to talk about that the whole time
right yeah just know you from TV they
just know you the characters that's not
you it's like a weird yeah so it's
sometimes it's very it's very weird I
knew she's gonna be we're going in but I
had a free night so yeah I don't kind of
want to see what it is that yeah I kind
of been putting it off for a minute yeah
and she was like kind of fun to talk to
like back and forth texting every now
and you get someone who's a good texture
and you're like why are you such a dud
get off the app as fast as possible
because then you wind out because some
people will waste your time texting
forever
right like oh this was such a waste yeah
I hate the apps although I did get
recognized on Grindr so this from a
torso it is just his torso
[Laughter]
guy who asked how my butthole would only
get it's such a crazy concept to put
your most precious item in the most like
thing you can do what you want to do
though it's like a glory hole
relationship I like all the porn I watch
I have to say it's like a woman being
used in like a and by a guy who's like
they're there why do I like glory hole
because the woman's just like a vessel
and she's not like a person and I don't
want to be not a person but I I want a
distant sex for me is so weird and it's
just so I have to disassociate to engage
in it because it is so you're like naked
[Music]
she like Elaine dances it's so
strange that you could be a dinner with
someone having a conversation it's so
hot and then cut to like boom you guys
are naked like inside of each other's
body pretty cool to get to that place
I was like a late bloomer so like all my
friends were hooking up before me and I
was always so fascinated by how do you
go from like doing nothing to doing that
like can we have sex not like move like
I just I'm so uncomfortable with that
transition and whenever my friends get
prostitutes I'm always like do they walk
in and comment on your sconces and then
they take off all their clothes and then
they're like how do you I always ask
them if they want something from
7-eleven do you and then I bring like a
Red Bull in like a snack you leave them
alone in your apartment no I go to them
that's what I do with my uber drivers
when they dropped me off at 7:00 when I
like make them stop I go do you want I
think so release them feel better and
they never do when they do I go really
we give people listening some tips cuz I
think that there are some that's oh
that's a lot of people have anxiety
about that first moment what's your
first move what's your go-to well I was
Kanye yeah yeah I do it's Kanye and I I
don't know if I have a move but it is it
is like it's like a tail like when you
know you know what's going down like hey
you want to go back to that you want to
go back to the house and chill and watch
a movie or something that's a very
standard old way to do I did not know
that that meant sex not for so long I
was movie don't just go there like
lights out you gotta you gotta go
through the motions like you don't know
what's happening gotcha
[Laughter]
that's a good one just come back to my
apartment we all know what that means
like we're having a good time let's keep
this going and go somewhere from the
time the time makes the time makes sense
to right it feels like 1:00 a.m. really
go I I don't want to stop hanging out
yeah that's that's that's where it
initiate so I almost got hanging out but
if you got to go home I can take you
home and then like depending on how how
the energy is right is kind of depend on
me what about like I was went on a date
with a guy not too long ago and and we
didn't know if it was a date or not it
was like friends hanging out than we
were at dinner and then we were like
let's go walk over here and get dessert
now let's walk over here and get tea and
now let's and then it got to a point
where was like okay we both and he
didn't ask me over and we're just
standing on the corner I'm calling an
uber and I'm like are we gonna kiss like
it was so awkward and then my uber shows
up and I'm like why and I just get in a
getaway car and I run away there could
have been a moment where he could have
kissed me or like something but it was
too awkward for us somebody on the
street somebody's got a do I yeah yeah I
make a move I don't wait for ya I've
been in and making the move it feels
good yeah but I've gotten rejected
before you know
[Laughter]
rejected and I pulled up a kid swinging
and missing at a t-ball games like
[Music]
making a decision she has every right to
make I go in where I didn't want him to
I think I'm very good about putting out
the energy of like don't kiss me right
now if I don't want it like I just give
them know anybody try where you're like
oh I didn't know no I think I'm pretty
good at not to say that women who do
have guys that triple they're asking for
it my favorite energy of like of new
relationships is when oh my gosh yes dr.
drew is back
hell yeah you know the best the best
energy ever is when you okay so say Ian
and I were like hanging out at a show or
something and we're sitting next to each
other and like I and we're not even on a
date it's just like a guy I'm sitting
next to that I'm like oh I could be into
him this is happen to me recently and I
love it where like you accidentally
touch but then you won't take it away
like Ian I could do like this cuz he's
my friend but if I wasn't into a guy
that is just my friend I or just someone
that I would never be I would touch and
I would instantly be like oh that's that
our space but when you just leave it and
they leave it and you go confirmation
it's not even just a point on your arm
where you do though your whole arm is
flush yeah it's like we have every all
the room not to do this right that is
the hottest that's what's fun about like
figuring out where people stand how you
feel about somebody those little
moments I love that like if you are
like saying hi to someone in another
night there was this guy that I had some
like energy with and so we were saying
hi and we he was shaking we were
greeting everyone and we just kind of
like that and I kind of just like held
on a little bit longer to be like hey
and you just give little indication
that's what she would known to me little
things but I will say the best I give
this advice to every guy who doesn't
know how to make a first move the best
first move I've ever had pulled on me
was on the street one of those like
we're both going our separate ways is
there gonna be a kiss at the end of the
night and when I was just kind of like
staring at the ground he just goes kid
over here and he just grabs my wrist
gently and kind of tugged me and it was
like it was just the way I really
recommend that move it's so hot it's
aggressive but not too aggressive it
really is a perfect Chris read you were
so great thank you so much for coming in
on you're so funny and so fun and I
can't wait to watch you just get more
and more successful stand-up you haven't
seen Chris read in the movie pop star
please watch him in that he is so he's a
breakout star in it but that movie is so
good I recommend it so much of course
watch at Caroline's tonight tonight
through Saturday he'll come out and hang
out with me I'm talking to go see Chris
read live at Caroline's this weekend
through Saturday starting tonight Chris
read thank you so much
Ian finance how's your butthole it's
amazing
Sileo we come to shows please come see
me at Philadelphia punchline bye
[Music]
you